talking about pensions isn't always
viewed as the most interesting thing to
do but hopefully this video and the next
one might convince you that it is at
least worth talking about and
understanding because it has major
implications for the fiscal situation of
many many many states in the u.s so a
pension is essentially a defined benefit
plan
defined
defined benefit plan for retirement
defined benefit plan and we can compare
that to a defined contribution plan
defined
contribution
contribution plan defined contribution
plan so in a defined contribution plan
and this is more typical in a lot of
private companies right now
every year that you work so let's plot a
little graph here
so this is years that you're working
and this is this is this is this is kind
of compensation
this is compensation right over here so
in defined contribution every year that
you work you're obviously going to make
your salary let's say you're making 60
000 a year
you're obviously going to make your
salary every year that you work and in a
defined contribution plan let's say this
is when you retire let's say for
simplicity we're assuming that you're
going to retire at 65 so at 65 you're no
longer going to be making your salary
anymore you're not working for that
company anymore but what the company
will do is set up some plan and a lot of
these are 401ks iras where some
combination of you and the company will
set some money aside and it's usually
done in a tax-deferred way so you don't
have to pay taxes on it in that year so
every year you're going to set some
money aside and i'll do this in green so
you're going to set maybe
maybe 10 of your income aside in every
year so these are every year and
actually the years are going to be much
smaller than that if we're thinking this
is about 30 years so over the 30 years
you're setting some level of money aside
and you're investing it you're putting
in the stock market you're buying bonds
in it with it you're buying mutual funds
who knows what you might be doing with
it so you're setting this money aside so
that when you retire it's it will
hopefully have grown because well one
it's there and if you've invested it and
hopefully if you've invested it well and
the stock market didn't do anything
crazy it will have grown and it will be
just a big lump sum of money so let's
say that you set aside 6 000 a year on
average for 30 years so you set aside
180 000
and let's say you invested it pretty
well and now that has grown to
oh i don't know let's say it's grown to
a million dollars because because it was
invested well we could do the math to
figure out what it could grow based on
different growth rates so you have this
huge this huge lump sum of money now so
i'm not even drawing it to scale so you
have this huge lump sum of money one
million dollars assuming it was invested
well if it was invested badly maybe 180
000 is maybe 180 thousand dollars is
still 180 thousand dollars in theory
maybe it was invested really badly it
could be even less than 180 thousand
dollars but whatever that number is
whether it's a 1 million or whether it's
200 000 or whether it's something
smaller that's essentially the money
that you have to live on for your
retirement regardless of how long you
live regardless of what the cost of
living might be regardless of what your
needs might be regardless of how how
expensive of your your your health care
might be this is going to be this is
going to be the money that you have to
live on so it might be more than enough
money if you invested well and you put
enough money aside it might be a lot
less than you need in which case you're
going to be tr in trouble and define
benefit plan and this is typical a lot
of state employees have defined benefit
plan
and a lot of more traditional industries
oftentimes that are unionized you also
have a defined benefit plan or a pension
the situation's a little different
just like any organization you will get
you will get your salary every year that
you work and let's just say that this is
over the course of 30 years so once
again you're retired age 65
you retire at age 65. but in defined
benefit plan the employer is going to
set aside some money and sometimes the
employee sets some money aside as well
so some money is set aside so once again
the money is set aside
the money is set aside and it is
invested hopefully in a safe way
and it's invested but regardless of what
that money and regardless of what that
turns into through an investment you are
guaranteed a certain degree of benefits
so in this case your degree you're
guaranteed let's say that if you've done
more than 20 years of service here you
get 60 of your last five years salary
and there's different ways of defining
that defined benefit it could be like
that it could be you get a hundred
dollars per month for every year that
you work at the organization you get 100
per month extra when you retirement when
you retire but they tend to be for life
for the rest of your life so from 65
until you pass away you are guaranteed
you are guaranteed this defined you are
guaranteed this defined benefit
and so if the money set aside if it was
set aside and invested well and happened
to be a lot more money than necessary
that's great but you all the employee
would get is this kind of guarantee but
if the money is less than necessary
then the company is still promising that
they are going to pay this pay this
benefit and they'll probably have to put
more or the state or whoever is doing
this would have to put more money in in
order to pay this compensation
now what are the things that you would
have to estimate if you were the person
setting aside this money to figure out
what you have to set aside in order to
give this defined benefit
well you're going to have to hire a
bunch of statisticians essentially
actuaries to say well how long are
people going to live so you're going to
have to care about lifespan
and obviously you can't predict any one
person's lifespan but if you're doing
this for hundreds of thousands of
employees maybe you can figure out what
a likely lifespan is you're going to
have to figure out cost of living
so inflation is a measure of cost of
living but it might be more specific to
the region or it might be negotiated in
some ways with the union so you're going
to have cost
of living
so this is a cost of living adjustment
when people talk about colas they're
talking about well if they're not
talking about soda they're talking about
cost of living adjustments you're going
to have to think about this money that
you set aside this money that you set
aside what is the assumed growth rate
what is the assumed
assumed growth rate if you make very
optimistic estimates of how well your
investments will do you can set aside
less money if you think that your money
isn't going to do well investment wise
you're going to have to put a put set
aside even more money
and this is one of the cruxes of the
issue because you can imagine let's say
that we're talking at a state level
and people are you know right now you're
let's say that you your current
actuaries the statisticians are saying
look for this person in order to
guarantee them 60 percent of their
salary when they retire so that's 36 000
in order to guarantee that we have to
put aside and i'm just i'm just i'm just
estimating these numbers right over here
let's say we have to set aside 6 000 a
year
6 000 a year especially when we're 30
years in advance actually let me do a
little bit more than that let's say 10
000 10 000 per year and let's say that
the the person in charge the state
official goes to those actors and says
well what are you assuming about how
much we're going to get on our
investments here and the actuaries are
saying well we're going to assume
we're going to assume a fairly
conservative we're going to assume that
we're going to get three percent three
percent return
on our money
but then the state official says oh well
you know i'd ideally they'd want some of
this ten thousand dollars per year to
spend on other things and so they would
like this to be lower and so they say
well that seems very conservative you
know in the last 10 years in the stock
market we've gotten 10 return or you
know i know an endowment that's recently
gotten 6 returns so why don't we assume
a higher return here so if we assume a
higher return
why don't we assume
why don't we assume a five percent
return and all of a sudden if we're
assuming a five percent return then
we'll have to set aside less money that
year
eight thousand a year and sometimes it's
not even this it's not even this playing
with the assumptions making more
optimistic assumptions that allow you to
spend less money in that current year
sometimes you might know that you are
not you know that you have to spend ten
thousand dollars a year to to kind of be
able to properly fund these pensions in
the future you do have some types of
unfunded pensions but in theory a
responsible party should try to fund
these as much as possible
you might know that you have to fund ten
thousand dollars a year in order to
credibly give this defined benefit for
this employee thirty years in the future
but thirty years in the future is a long
time and you have present difficulties
you have present shortfalls in your
budget you say okay i recognize that i
have to put ten thousand dollars a year
but you still don't do that so you under
fund the pension so even if you
recognize this or if you recognize this
you still only put five thousand dollars
a year really just kind of kicking the
can down the road hoping that the next
guy or gal who's in your position is
going to figure out something or maybe
you'll just be very optimistic that the
growth will turn out or the the the
state will eventually
work things out and what we'll see over
the next video this notion of
underfunding pensions
under funding
underfunding pensions is a big big big
big problem because we've had decades of
underfunded pensions and it's been
especially pronounced in particular
states and because of that those states
in order to fund the pension obligations
that are hitting now
those expenses for employees that are
retired are starting to grow beyond
their their budgets for the employees
that are working right now and it's a
tough issue you can't cut these things
very easily people expected these these
are retirees these are people who've
been working their whole life based on
this assumption but at the same time if
they're starting to squeeze out a key
services that the state is doing it it
turns into a major major hairy issue